let's bring in Andrew Brant columnist at
the Monday Morning Quarterback
former NFL executive and we thought we
would bring in Andrew former NFL
executive he could dumb this down for
the for us and our audience or at least
for me Andrew thanks for joining us on
short notice
I mentioned this when I started the show
I get nervous whenever the owners are
excited about something and how they
sort of been using us in the media to
send this message out what do you make
of is this one sided with the owners
versus the players hey Dan I do have to
come in use those three words I remember
going on set at Sports Center or NFL
live and hearing my producer tell me in
my ear hey Andrew dumb it down right
listen the owners want this deal and why
do they want the deal because they want
to go to the network's digital media
sponsors etc and say hey we got 10 years
of labor piece don't worry about it
there's no lockout there's no strike
there's no work stoppage buy in and
spend all the money you have because
we're a product that's going to continue
they want the deal now rather than the
uncertainty of potential labor problems
in 13 months I get it
the question is are the players getting
bit using this leverage enough to get
the concessions that they want and what
have we heard from players the past 1 2
5 10 years no way no how
we're playing more than 16 games and so
much hypocrisy from the NFL talking
about safety and health while making us
wanting us to play more games yet here
we are we're talking about a deal being
voted on today that includes an extra
game or inventory for teams which is
great is it great for players you know
we can talk about some of the deal
points it just seems like they could get
more out of this for the leverage they
have which they never have leverage yeah
because they want the deals so bad the
owners well I don't want a 10-year deal
if I'm a member of The Players
Association like ten years is in
eternity and it feels like you know
maybe five
because I don't know what the I don't
know what media is gonna be like then I
don't I don't know if it's you know I
know you like to say I like what's in
front of me and I know what's in front
of me and that's great the NFL keeps
growing and growing growing it feels
like in five years this deal is going to
be outdated yeah I mean that's my first
criticism I just don't get the idea of a
decade-long deal and no other NF no
other PA has this they have five-year
deals or seven eight-year deals that
have an opt outs after three or four you
know I know why the owners want a
ten-year deal of course but like you
just said the economics are going to
look so different and maybe even two
years with the new media companies and
again the new media deals are not just
going to be ESPN ABC NBC Fox they're
going to include Google and Yahoo and
Twitter and Amazon so what are we
talking about here
we're talking about the NFL being very
strategic in the way they negotiate and
I did it for 10 years as a player
negotiator I'm honest what I did was I
try to entice players to take a deal
with a lot of upfront and early
enticements and then you lock them in
with cost certainties for a lot listen
some of the things that are going to be
on that NFL PA conference call today is
going to be hey guys 100,000 increase on
the minimums and 100 million in 2020
that we wouldn't have if we did this if
we didn't do this deal 100 million is 3
million per team come on and then you
know and then you get to 47% and you get
to 48 percent at forty eight point five
percent which sounds good but then it
stopped then you got eight years I
bought up my first and maybe major
cruisers I'm like why are we doing a
ten-year deal with no opt-out but I also
worry about the haves and the have-nots
here to Andrew because these guys who
are already making their money and now
you're adding a 17th game
and if your contracts already signed you
know is there a cap on how much you can
earn for that seventeenth game it's
great for the backup linebacker but you
know Aaron Rodgers and JJ Watt know
trotting out there they can't be too
thrilled about this I would imagine I
don't get this in if the NFL really
wants to make a deal why do this you
know why do this
why make players that make more than
$200,000 a week and I know people are
like that so much money but listen these
are high-value people in the
entertainment industry
so if Aaron or Russell Wilson or or by
that time time Holmes or whoever it is
is taking a twenty thirty fifty hundred
percent pay cut you know what why is the
end of it why is the NFL even proposing
that oh by the way you know with the 17
games the guys make a lot of money are
gonna take a big haircut I mean come on
what is in the NFL's reasoning that they
just wouldn't pay the prorated portion
of that seventeenth game starting next
year to me if the NFL really wants to
make a deal and maybe they're holding
this little point we're talking about as
the closer maybe but it just seems to me
odd they're trying to make a deal with
that provision how do we get the 17
games scheduled the actual schedule
what's it look like where's that 17th
game played we have no details but I'm
guessing international because we've
gone London we've gone from one to two
to four games I think we'll end up at
eight we won't have a London team will
have a London schedule between three
stadiums 16 teams a year that half the
league the rest of the league
I don't know Mexico Toronto heard about
Germany and it just seems like the
logical extension is going to be that
17th game becomes international and I
don't maybe that began maybe it's a
domestic game somewhere take a city that
st. Louis San Diego I don't
so that's my thought but it got a year
to figure that out Andrew thanks for
joining us if you were telling the
player talking to the players today what
would you advise them to do with this
deal this proposal I guess what I would
say is even though the NFL is making it
seem like it - take it or leave it and
final proposal there's always room for
more continue to negotiate I think we
can do better
Andrew thank you we appreciate it
always a pleasure Dan that's Andrew
Brent always makes me smarter columnist
at Monday Morning Quarterback and course
former NFL executive for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]